oh um whoops just crash the lens Oh No
Microsoft Word watch Game of Thrones
last night and he's like I gotta go I'm
gonna grab my keys grab my keys thinking
they're his keys and like made him think
that these were his keys
well I just wanted Nico's car really bad
dude not only you the guy who like takes
care of the building not the landlord
but let his helper he's offered to buy
my car twice what why apparently like 98
accord just like right at the cusp of
like everything's still like analog and
mechanical and works great but like it
smells like power windows and AC and I'm
like a modern car so like my car's yeah
right that lining to fix everything easy
sounds good man thanks a lot what you
just jacked your keys man - the old
switcheroo
Gavin c-coming is this Yuki your house
no I forgot
that's Cuban floor and I just like the
color of it now hey if you guys met Gabe
whatever you guys need me to do oh I
guess mostly draw Starboard's Kahn so
far as mainly what I did whatever your
name is draw like a drawing my Cintiq
it's a 13 inch I got it used from guys
to work with who's good in school I
pretty much stole it off him pretty
cheap price cash it's been like a year
and a half
what did you do what I do what did you
do this didn't stay on the thing it fell
off when I was writing and then I wrote
over it you may have a very scratch to
lens oh dude you guys got a one wheel oh
you know it before but like everyone is
like really hard okay okay it ain't
likely forward or back it's easier when
you're in motion so if you're going it's
actually not too bad
through the grace of a thousand gazelles
oh this is so hard the problem with this
is like it's literally like a 1 it
launches out from one of your feet if
you're going too fast
is there something I'm missing here all
right guys yeah okay I'm getting the
hang of it just working on the store
works for the first animation hopefully
get close this week aren't just around
social media first see people like it if
it works Instagram Facebook yeah so
people like it then we'll do more well
see if it comes out good you may be
there there playing with little toys
there the pterodactyl and then yes baby
from there there's definitely a scratch
right there in the center of the lens
that's not good why were we not using a
lens protector I didn't even think about
it
those there before we got that Oh was it
okay good then maybe the scratch was
already there yeah the scratch was
already there how do I turn it on like
that there we go
sweet I know how to do it that didn't
sound good